quickly
thank you agenda item five
Pokemon Crouch Essex removal of various
structures
and construction available
absolutely
speaking here
is that
hear me
handrails and Jetty to access new access
page and the floating pontoon the
support piles to serve four
um that time there shows the of the
application site on the key
and again shows the application site so
it includes name the single red line on
either side
side and that is the access way a
walkway is part of the application and
the blue land is landed within the
ownership of the African Communications
and modern Castle
so the the site is um an Intel
intertidal mudflaps
um it is within the conservation area of
Berlin and also there are listed
buildings in the vicinity of sites as
set out in the papers
this is an existing block plan showing
the site which until recently had as I'm
sure the members will be aware
um had the um
like
um within it but that has recently gone
and the book plan has been updated to
reflect that
and this is a proposed layout plan for
the site so that shows the um the
Pontoon going down the middle of the
site before houseboats to either side
and also the walkway when you walk
whether it's going to be always proposed
um along the shore side of the
um
uh
the the wall fences and it also shows
the location of the um proposed bin
store on the left hand side there and
which would link the site with the
pliers Boatyard
these December cross section so the
first one the top is looking so there's
the walkway in the background and just
has also got the houseboats and
um outside on there and then the second
one is looking
um from the East at high tide again
showing the houseboats there with the
Pontoon
um full high tide level and then the
lower one the bottom one is where at low
tide where the houseboats and pontoon
would lower down onto the onto the metal
Flats
and then I've got some photos here
um
looking the top two or looking towards
Pryor's Boatyard
um with the application site on the left
hand side and also Google street view
from The High Street on that second on
Sunday
and some
um other photos of the other top ones
looking
um you know the direction towards one of
the existing aspects and the thing that
the the bottom one is taken from a
slightly further distance
and also do it quick um Google Earth
view showing the site
um showing their location of the site
and that's with the these headaches
still insecurement and operation at the
time they that view was taken
so in terms of um uh the assessment of
the application officers feel their
principal is acceptable and that the
proposal would actually contribute
towards the council's five year housing
Supply and The Proposal complies with
the manual effect obviously in their
local pandemic to the provision of
houseboats policy h8
would be acceptable
and the president was also accepted from
in relation to highways Federal risk and
nature conservation and and so therefore
which recommend for approval subject to
the conditions that are in the papers
and but also
um slightly amended by the update that's
been circulated
um yesterday thank you
thank you very much
um
I think I should declare that I am in
favor of the scheme up to a point
that the the burn water fund has slowly
becoming externalized uh and Jetties are
not being repaired by their owners
and I I would love to see the whole
world if I would be invigorated indeed
and involved in a charity called the
banker Administration trust which is all
about that
um so in principle the idea of returning
at least two households to that location
where there were houseboats before I
can't see how anybody could possibly
object to it on the grounds that that
would be just simply re-establishing
what historically has been there I think
where the project runs into problems is
is with the four houseboats and that's
one of the problems for a number of
reasons the first is is that there are
um
that there's a feeling certainly in the
town that that is pushing it that's too
much that's uh that's a crowd hiding in
an area where there's a short
facilities
some people have raised the issue of the
conservation area but I don't think that
can really apply to a river and doesn't
indeed as we often proved in in parts of
London but it doesn't apply where it
involves boats so that um you can bring
more boats to a to a waterfront I was
once involved in a big legal case and
open this but the problem here is that
there are four boats rather than two and
that has all sorts of costifications
which means the rents are going to have
to be very high and if the rents are
going to be very high that's going to
put people off and there may be a
financial viability issues in that area
because they're so exposed to the
dramatic the southwesterly prevailing
winds we have and when you get a bit
when you get a strong tide in the
southwest uh it's a sort of wind from
the south west uh you can have
especially at the lower part of that
tidal area of in the sort of the boats
of the further out on the truck they
could be exposed to more problems
um and uh of course as I'm sure some
people will wear anyway the biggest
problems are from the Northeast so and
the East perhaps when you get flooding
in the river when you get big blows from
the Northeast and Southeast so and
whatever is built there is going to have
to be built very very strong to handle
continually in those type of their
conditions my personal feeling is
great to have houses the houseboats and
burn the better as far as open so but I
think we must fall and I'd recommend
operation and more sustainable
which would be kind of establishing
instead of being there
kind of decision tonight okay
thank you
expressed
because it is
yeah I think um
houseboats
because it's
yeah
I think it's exactly the same uh the
same as you hear
all those which is something we've done
around
development
so I'm on the uh
customer assistance
[Music]
but that was a person and it was
somewhere else
the schemes that the members speak to
the Town Council to see if they do
is I know it's been addressed chairman
and forgive me but I couldn't see what
what part of an address situation I've
made so what what is it back in place
uh yeah thank you chairman okay
um there's no obstetric parking proposed
for that close
um but the officers
will be supposed to counting and
disabilities are there but he um
because
they've been done and the Earth
parking
and we wishes
that's a lot of money to pay for a place
which you don't own and which you
haven't got parking so I've got big
problems with the whole reality
Financial reality and I think that
it might be more reasonable though that
I take the Chairman's point about um
you've got planning reasons but it might
be reasonable to uh I mean even if we
approved it for the council facility
consider will actually go ahead and it's
going to be financially viable with all
the problems it may cause but yes I
think you need to find somewhere to find
car parking and I did suggest talking to
the Town Council because problems car
park is just across the road and if you
could have a financial deal which would
bring money into Burnham Town Council
that would be a potential solution
whilst there's no planning objections
I was also concerned that there was
either the castle as a landowner and
developer could look into our
opportunities that may or may not be
available in the town for for parking so
um so it's an issue that the council
could address
um perhaps through other committees and
other other
um as a landowner rather than through
the planning process yeah with what
we're doing because we're trying to
wander off from too many gear actually
too much
is is this Jetty and the proposal for it
a good idea or not oh well
something like car parking can all be
tied up through lease lease agreements
to the to the to the residents when it
happens five six thousand years and
certain gym to me and being in the late
sales Affairs but don't forget about
this please
you've got to buy the house you know
sort of advisors
I mean after that in the next stage if
Planning Commission was approved then
obviously we'd have to take a message
back and the council will then have to
work out if this scheme was actually
viable because they've done it well
done already yeah well they may be wrong
the chairman the clue to this that we're
talking
I mean the clue to this channel
Miss Matthews could just remind me what
the application number is or with almost
um
so it's been this has been under
consideration for you know best case
scenario three years and and
all of the non-planning issues that
members have brought up this evening
have been fully debated in the Arts as
well with Hearst elsewhere generally
I'll give way to counselor
gazelle thank you you've been waiting
for a long time
so
it's all disability before votes
yeah
we're looking at the application in
front of us
around the officers recommendations
there's no good wandering around trying
to get elsewhere over there you can't do
that right I've seconded counselor house
proposal
thank you and yeah look you know it's
obviously is a little bit controversial
but you know
you say about four boats too but
you know when I listen to the report
you'd see that this is
Association officer
um something just got to be just accept
that
um
their objections
we just
the idea well I think this is all to do
with the fact that this is
commission I mean I I thought
should look
like and I think within the conditions
that person's nephews if you could
there's quite available in a houseboat I
think in one of the signs perhaps we've
just go down and it's not capsized
yeah I think that was interesting yeah
yeah I mean yeah
that we're not going to Aspire to and I
think there's enough conditions easier
to control that so that's a certain
condition and I mean whether or not it
would be the right proper Improvement to
just say that you know any decisions
over those houseboats should be taken
away from what they look like
conjunction with Ward members because I
mean I don't know how I mean what lived
in more than like
I know but I remember as a child when
the house houseboats from war memorial
all the way to Creekside and and they
all hit the pld and everything else lots
of all next military Navy
and it's just condensed out so you know
based on I think what councilor Helen
said and councilman Chan is about to say
because I know that she's seconded in
recommendation I certainly support them
can't see any reason to turn this down
just to say the issues in the report
were some I want to reverse concerns are
mentioned I noticed that the conditions
cover left or not as such anyway
everything has been dealt with by those
conditions before this committee so that
is why I feel I can second and actually
I think it is good scheme
as far as I can tell apart from the Town
Council all the statutory Council to you
so no objections
initial ones but their concerns have
been answered so
really we have you know we've moved with
us fun to come up with a refusal that
isn't going to get the support of a
statutory consultation
I still go back to the to the point
where you know it's made something to be
no further than any other
do but there is no other pontoon
so we are in fact setting the precedent
we are doing something that isn't there
and hasn't been there before there are
lines of houseboats but there is there
is no point there is no other pontoon
that has houseboats going out into the
river so therefore we are doing
something new this is something out of
character as far as I'm concerned and
when I gather all that Waterfront I see
rows of houseboats I don't see
houseboats going out into the water and
it may serve us to have houseboats going
out so we get the revenue but to be
honest as a planning application this is
something that isn't there and we are
doing something new and we are setting
the president and we will be having
pontoons going out with other people
stringing houseboats
passenger we are not qualified to seem
to say that we are only qualified to
look at what we are looking at what we
are looking because we cannot say
whether or not anybody will want to
build a prompt tune a lot if they
somebody else comes along with an
application
considered in its own right yeah
on this application we do have an
application that is
not the same as what's there it's
something different it's a positive
going now it's houseboats and I don't
see why we are looking at it as if it's
like the others are the same okay
it's not it's not relevant so this
discussions
applications
or we don't support it well hopefully we
have a debate but if you don't want to
say
let's just have a vote I mean you know I
thought we were here but clearly no
wanted to hear it so let's just vote Gem
and I actually would feel a little bit
of sympathy for cancer passenger doesn't
cancel it no I do because Council of
glucose raised the thing about this has
been on the car since 2019. we can talk
about the Caravan site down in Burnham
that's been there since 2012 and still
hasn't been sorted out so I think it's a
little bit disingenuous to actually use
that as an example and try to sort of
say well you did cancel food because you
can look at personal just what what you
like but the thing is uh you know we are
allowed to debate and and maybe it does
go off tap a little bit but it's no
different than another committing this
Council operates and Chairman's allow
people to speak and I I and we said it
the other day about stopping being able
to speak just because it maybe you don't
feel canceled on the planning department
it has been it's relevant it can be
relevant and it comes into future issue
to this town so I don't think it's very
fair that we've been stopped all our
arguments have been put oh yeah it's not
a planning issue you shouldn't discuss
it because as long as I'm a counselor I
discuss what I want as long as I'm not
abusive at the meetings sure podcast I
mean
we seem to drift from the planning
application and talk about the economics
and the scheme the cost of the scheme
the engineering of the scheming
relations and I think you refer to wind
events tide
and the reason why I mentioned the 19 is
because the reason why is everyone to
come to Quincy that
is because this whole process has been
going through the council's Committees
subcommittees and I think even to a
working group at one stage and all of
those things have been dealt with and
that's what I was saying and that's
what's been happening since 2019 and
today we are here looking at paying the
application to build a pontoon for four
houseboats
[Music]
nothing else
uh just briefly uh the reason why it is
right now is because of this headings
left yeah there's nothing to do I mean
definitely go to the numerous committees
how well it's been studied I don't know
my feeling is that um I think the
council may have got his figures rolling
here but that's not a planning issue I
understand it I'm sympathetic with um
Council passenger because he's
reflecting the opinion and even if
they're not just you know Dairy planning
issues they have to be aired that is a
part of our job
just to finish my point
anything
like that thing
what I'm saying is what we have to do as
a committee to avoid getting ourselves
in the muddle
look at this on the planning
applications you're not looking at it on
the financial side we're not looking at
it on any other side sure we're not
looking at it out of the wind of the
body effect so anything else like that
that we are not qualified to answer and
it's not planning which we can look at
this purely as a planning application so
I'm not trying to stop discussion in
fact I've allowed a considerable
abandoned discussion you've been going
three minutes
I don't reject that but I do object to
wandering off in too many different
directions and aren't actually relevant
to the decision that we make at the end
of it
okay I think people are just correct
what people said but yes you're right
it's got to be we've got to make a
planning decision and if we fit and if
we've got a good reason to refuse it we
need to come up with it okay
well unless anybody else has got
anything new to add to it we've got a
proposal my counselor Helm secondary by
councilor this is Channer to approve the
application as per the officer
recommendation could be anything please
don't by all means
um they'll be in a position
because those in favor of the of the
approvals yeah there's in favor of the
of the approval peace show
s and
I will support the office of
recommendation on this one so I don't
often get involved in this stage but I
will on this case those are games please
show
so
passenger hang yourself
okay and in that case the application is
approved by five to three
oh and uh
mistake
thank you
excuse me chair I'm sorry to say but I I
have to fly I I only just made this
meeting I was a nine years
we've been so far thank you thank you
sure
good to be here
okay now
vendor items six
uh the Hawthorn scalpy Road southminster
proposal is a material change of use of
land for the south of the existing site
to Hawthorns and sighting of an
additional mobile home permanent
residential occupation and Associated
access Gateway driveway and hard
standing grasp immunity area of brand
new fencing and Landscaping which before
this committee is a departure from the
local band 2017 with an officer
recommendation to approve to both
thank you chair
um my apologies uh to you and the
committee I'm having some difficulty
presenting
the slides
of the application
um
drugs
yeah
yes I think that's the one on the screen
yes that one yeah
sounds good
foreign
basis so in town planning of terms
technically it's a use of the lab to
have the Caravan on but the the Caravan
would be better on a permanent basis is
so effectively it would be
a structure although a structure that
could be moved
um you'll see the uh the map on the
right hand side of the slide there with
the site
um marked
in red
um
another slide here
shows the society a little more detail
the
um part of the red line site to the
north is where there is
and then the southern
half of the red line site is currently a
horse Paddock
um
I'll go through this fairly quickly
because I think the photographs towards
the end
will make things clearer this is a drop
down with the existing mobile home
to the north to the top of the
the site there uh Sculpey Road over on
the right hand side and the proposal is
to put a mobile home
bottom left-hand corner so it would be
the far left hand corner of the existing
horse Paddock
as from Sculpey Road
the plan also shows the humidity area
towards the front of the site a parking
area
there will be a fly Chester biotesque in
the right hand side of the site of the
proposal going across guys Road into a
ditch on the far side
going into details there
this Photograph shows
what has been displayed with the map the
site location plan
the
existing mobile home is
um
towards the top of the illustration
there there's another structure of a
mobile home type
further to the north
[Music]
to the south of the Hawthorns is the
horse Paddock
essentially the subject of the planning
application then another horse Paddock
and then
um
a mobile home Target structure to the
South and Banco on the opposite side
of scalby Road
foreign
you can see that
this is by no means in open Countryside
it's uh it's on a track
not highway it's a private road and
there's
similar development around and the
scattering of residential units
and
I thought that this slide showed South
Windsor but it
it doesn't but what you can see from
this is uh top right hand corner of the
slide
you can make out there is a footpath
that in fact leads to South Windsor and
there's a public path along the track
to the west of Skyway Road along the
Scarborough Road
the next photo is of the site itself
um it's it's a horse Paddock you can
just make out the fence
to the right hand side there of the
Hawthorns
and on the next
slide
you can see
just on the right hand side there the
existing mobile home of the Hawthorns
um
there's a fence along the uh The Far
Side
I do have better photographs this was
taken early on the application
an equally bad photo I'm sorry but this
is of the Hawthorns you can see
um the white paintable
of the Hawthorne structure
a slightly more recent photograph
the uh the main body of The Proposal is
to put the
mobile home fire electing corner of the
horse Paddock to the right hand side you
can see there's enough of horse Paddock
to the left on the sides to the South
you can get an idea of the existing
structure of the Hawthorns
um in the slide there with the immunity
block
that uh brick Gable to the rear
and uh this is a general view of Sculpey
Road uh drainage would go under the road
to a ditch you you can just make out the
line of the ditch along that that line
of trees
really going back
The Proposal is essentially for a new
dwelling we don't as yet quite have a
five-year housing land Supply
and
[Music]
um
this
this proposing would not affect the
amenity or character or beauty of the
countryside because it's it's not really
an Open Country it's set along a private
road
it isn't as bad as many sites in terms
of sustainability and you'll see that
the history
includes an inspector's report
that talked about the sustainability so
um
in terms of not
having any material impact on the
character of the countryside I mean in
terms of an inspector saying this was
acceptable in terms of its sustainable
location the recommendation is one of
approval
thanks Jeff with just a clarification
this is not ancillary to the existing
mobile home at the orthons which is a
separate unit of accommodation
the physical structure would be separate
but it would be used
like an Annex essentially it would be
occupied by
um
no idea what's going on
so will the third they'll be using this
answer what's he gives you know
absolutely
it is
self-contained as a separate
[Music]
um it's just bearing that in mind
we quickly get funding applications for
weddings of All Sorts right throughout
old teeth yeah yeah oh we're getting
kind of worms to ourselves
I would say no because the
characteristics of this particular site
are such that it it wasn't being the
open Countryside it isn't
um a plot upright surrounded by a Fields
along a public Highway
the The Proposal matches the character
of the setting but then that argument
also applies to all the other housing
plots
well with this particular site taking in
mind what an inspector said with regard
to the Hawthorns refusal would be
um
not the not the way to go I would
suggest I move on can't figure it okay
thank you very much chairman I think
maybe I can not read this report from
you but as far as I can see reading this
report and remembering the inspector's
appeal uh first up I would just say that
there has been lots of planning
inspectors who have found that old teeth
use other sustainable it's an
unsustainable location full stop nobody
said anything else however
when the Hawthorne's application can
be it came forward as part of a travel
Travelers family application and which
means the sustainability test is much
lower than if it hadn't been so what
inspector said was because this was a
cabinet family the sustainability test
was much lower and that's why I accepted
it but only for those reasons not on the
overall sustainability area because we
know it's a long way away so based on
the pan aspective report
for that purpose
I was quite concerned
very much the same as you you are but
I'm hoping I'm going to turn your mind
now because I actually thought I'm
neutral I I uh
um
but the key issue to this is computer
goes that's what southeast Parish
Council responded and I will say that
I'm a member College
but they were concerned that this was
going to be a separate dwelling on the
site and actually when you read the
report when you read these people it
doesn't really mention anything about it
being ancillary and Annex or anything
until you actually get to the conditions
and and that's where Gemini was totally
harmed
under
a condition number four it says that the
mobile home here are permitted
shall not be occupied at any time other
than for the purpose of ancillary to the
residential use of the dwelling known as
the whole forms and then it actually
goes on it gives weight to that channel
and actually says who can live in it I
mean I I I mean I've never seen anything
like this
tied up like this before but it wouldn't
appear that this is
it says the site should not be occupied
by a person other than the sun or
daughter-in-law Mr Michael Perkins and
Senior and any Resident depending on the
summer so this is absolutely you know
this is absolutely bolted down yes so
based on that and and having having
known scalby Road for a long long time
um Jim and I would propose that we agree
the officer's recommendation thank you
very much
[Music]
but the report is very clear to me in
saying it's actually a dwelling on the
site because it refers to it that
performing part of our housing stock and
it talks about the driveway
so to me this is totally the new
dwelling but then the conditions don't
reflect that
so could I have that explained because I
don't think I can say something
contribute to the housing stock if a
condition says it sounds similar to the
existing
well actually I'm sorry I didn't make
that clear I
I didn't
I want sort of my
um the point that technically what is
being applied for is the use of the land
to be used
to park a mobile home on now that mobile
home would to all the intents and
purposes
be a dwelling
um
I'm not sure if that was made
anything any clearer yeah
the condition says that we are very
certain people obviously associated with
things
this was out of the housing stock
therefore how can
happen yes
all right
well I I would say
to the housing stock
in that fight somewhere for a family to
live and so is those broad terms it
would indeed out of the housing stock
foreign
in this life to live in
way as an ancillary to accommodation it
wasn't allowed a kitchen
then
the ancillary to the house
I'm not safe
any other members
currency as well because I'd love to
stick one of these in my back Garden big
enough but I've always been told you
couldn't you you can't do it because
it's it would be able to run into the
site and it's not
um attached to the the property so I
think it's really important we do it's
either a separate dwelling which to be
quite honest with you I'm actually
having to support it if it's a separate
wedding but if it's going to be labeled
an Annex I think we're on a difficult
brand there because I will stick one in
my button
[Music]
it would be able to be accommodated
so are we voting on a separate countries
yes yeah
[Music]
if I could just come back that we we
have not remember this because it was in
your ward and I was like
okay but we have to see plan alone and
you may well remember where someone put
it in massive residential Caravan in
their front guard and we were told that
there was no problem doing that because
it was for a member of the family they
didn't need for that information for
that one and as long as it didn't have a
flashing to do and a kitchen or
something in the kitchen was always
acceptable and you've sat there and told
yourself to a house so you know I'll be
the first to let your daughter know that
you're making a
professionals
German but this in all seriousness
because it is somebody's obviously
application is are these conditions then
correct yeah so they're correct it's
going to be called an ancillary
self-contained
the weather in fact it is a separate
planning unit although it's referred to
that too but it does have
the red line
is set up to report well I think
chairman is
um but
um it's so they said to president for a
lot more
developments it's Jesus because I know
if you're in Berlin that experience okay
okay we get back to the point because
it's a problem yeah the case there is a
proposal in front of us to approve the
application is that a seconded
I can't
five
and there he Gates no in that case it is
the application is approved
a Generation 7 has been with groom which
means we move on to a gender item any
other items business in general he
designs are Urgent I have none
it comes from our Associates on this
channel I don't know if it's relevant to
the meeting having spent two thousand
pounds donated the council for the
recording equipment and it's
through I'm very disappointed what's
going on tonight it's absolutely
respectful
so if they want to sort it out
to return to the meeting so it would
have come tonight and say the least yeah
in which case I'm now closed the meeting
at 8 59. thank everybody for your
attention